roll it I in this space of bringing
together communities that span a variety
of backgrounds to talk in the space of
data rights Thanks everyone it's really
lovely to be here I have to say it's
especially nice to see Nick so hi Nick I
wasn't expecting to be here
this is really a treat for me I've spent
a past couple years forcing myself on
computer scientists and and it's a it's
a privilege to be in a group where I can
kind of discuss some ideas that you will
find in sufficiently rigorous and you
will hopefully have some rigorous things
to say about it so today I really took
the opportunity to try to speak to the
theme of the workshop I'll be talking
about some joint work I've done with
Karen Levy who's also at Cornell which
we're calling privacy dependencies this
is a paper that we have been draft now
and I'll kind of just jump into it to
give you some sense of what I mean by
this term so master there were a couple
things that happened I got people to
think about the fact that our individual
privacy is often dependent on what we
know about other people and so on the
one hand we had the scandal around
Cambridge analytic Oh which involved
being able to access information about
our friends and friends of friends if I
remember correctly and then just a month
later at the Golden State State's killer
case which was I'll describe more if I
get there in time involved using genetic
information of a relative to track down
this particular killer and these were
kind of both pointed to you and some
popular raatein as this interesting
example of how our intimate associations
in this case our friends and family can
expose us even if we have not revealed
anything ourselves and Karen and I
wanted to kind of think more sweepingly
about how this is true not just these
two particular cases but across the many
different mechanisms in which this is
possibly true and I should start by
saying that of course I recognize that
differential privacy as a definition of
privacy as something that is trying to
deal with a particular problem is in his
own way trying to respond to the fact
that we're able to figure out things
about
based on information we know about
others and I'll get there at some point
but I think I also want to situate this
and I kind of broader or set of work
which is trying to think about privacy
beyond individual privacy and there's a
couple of things I think that are
relevant here so the first is this
long-standing work on the broad social
value of privacy you and you can concede
what this is the idea that there is
collective value to living in society
where we have individual privacy rights
all right it allows us to do things to
cultivate ideas and associations that
serve a collective interest it also been
worked on on group privacy some of the
earliest work of group privacy was a
kind of narrow conception it was sort of
this idea that we should have the right
to huddle to kind of have certain group
associations but there's been more
recent work over the past decade that is
really looking at the idea that there
might be a privacy interest in the
statistical properties the group to
which we belong and those I think are
kind of two relevant areas of literature
I'll be talking about as closer to these
two final categories mark McCarthy an
article in 2011 and this idea of privacy
externalities where the information that
I disclose might have some kind of
externality in a sense might implicate
other people who did not disclose and
then in a more recent piece by fearful
denying goal there's a similar
conception here where it's privacy is a
kind of public good where we're sort of
compromising the public good when we
make our own individual decisions and
what I'll try to do today is give a
little bit of detail to these two final
ideas I'm gonna set aside the first two
which I think we're sort of well trodden
and I'm gonna suggest that there's
actually quite a lot to think about in
these two final categories and what I
should say is that this work focused on
exactly this problem right so the idea
that if we're not necessarily in control
of what others can know about us because
there are other people whose disclosures
implicate us then this whole conceit of
notice of consent is just fundamentally
flawed so this is sort of the style of
argument that these papers were
developing trying to show that like this
is really not a matter of individual
choice in any meaningful sense what I
preferred to talk about today something
slightly different while I think what
I'll describe will further reinforce
that view
I want to kind of study the details of
these different mechanisms which I'm
going to call dependencies and I want to
try to tease out what I think are the
different normative values that attach
to these different situations and
hopefully we can consider it
collectively some of the different
relevant social practices policies and
particularly some technical
interventions that help us deal with
these dependencies and so I'll say at
the start that I Karen I identify three
the highest level we say that there's
three different types of dependencies so
one we call ty based another similarity
based and the final is DIF based and to
preview a little bit a lot of the work
on differential privacy is really this
last category okay well let me just jump
into it so oh I should say that like
this is really meant to kind of like
stimulate discussion about problems that
are here kind of very stylized and not
Rea rigorous and I would love people to
interrupt if they think this is
something that they want to talk about
more so let me let me start so yes okay
that's another good point so we're not
the are titian so there was no attempt
to even you know aim for
comprehensiveness but it was meant to be
it like a pretty exhaustive exercise we
wanted to really think can we capture a
lot of different things or we we took
comfortable thinking that we've done a
decent job of exploring the space but
I'm totally open to the idea that we've
missed things completely or that people
might have other examples or that this
taxonomy is you know not sufficient so
yeah okay so to begin type is is what
we're thinking of is we're at a
situation where I'm able to sort of I'm
using Alice involved as the convention
here and I'll use the observer as a
person who's sort of learning things
about I'm gonna say Bob in this case
right so an observer in this case is
able to learn things about about Ellis
late on let me yeah about Ellis no not
great when you get tripped up on their
first slide okay a situation where their
observer is gathering information about
Alice but learns about Bob by virtue of
learning something about Elvis and here
it could be that they're sort of
capitalizing on the fact that Alice and
Bob have a relationship and taken
do that and sometimes it can also be an
attempt to sort of make more sense of
what the observer has learned about
Ellis by learning something about Bob
but here we kind of pack in a bunch of
different scenarios that are quite
distinct where this seems to be what's
going on so I'll just quickly summarize
them here then go one by one so on one
case we can identify an unknown Bob by
virtue of his relationship to unknown
Alice and I'll say I'll give the example
of genetic information in a minute we
can also pick you back on observations
of Alice to get at Bob or maybe we can
incentivize Alice to disclose
information about Bob or actually their
opposite direction which is that we can
potentially incentivize Bob to get
information about himself because he
wants to be able to have some kind of
communication with Alice that is
facilitated by for instance a social
network and then this kind of formal
category which might be pushing the
boundaries here is the argument that
were justified and searching associates
of Alice because they are sorry
searching collect information about
because Bob is an associate of Alice
right this will come to refer to stuff
like government surveillance okay so the
first case is maybe the most
straightforward one which is the kind of
this was the familial search right so we
find a DNA sample at a crime scene we
don't know who it belongs to you but
there now exists you know these large
databases of identified DNA samples and
what we might want to do is check to see
if there's any partial match in that
database which might tell us that the
person who was at the crime scene is at
least some relative of the of the person
who was there right and the sort of
property is about DNA that also can tell
us who that relative is right is that
their sister is that their child is it
their cousin and so on so we can
actually learn quite a lot even if we
don't necessarily know who this sample
refers to you and so having this
particular relationship this particular
quality allows us to potentially
identify Bob because Alice was willing
to disclose her information to for
instance 23andme or one of these
companies that now maintains these
databases and I think this is the
scenario that has probably become most
familiar to people right they have a
pretty decent
sense that your relatives willingness to
participate in these things that somehow
compromise in your privacy a slightly
different situation is what we can think
of a sort of incidental observation
where Bob is essentially caught in the
net of information that's being
collected about Alice some of this can
be really trippy all like I'm in the
background of some of the students that
are being photographed graduating from
Berkeley and even though the intent
wasn't necessarily to take a picture of
me I'm sort of a bystander that gets
captured it can be a bit more kind of
purposeful right so I install certain
equipment in my house which collects
information about me but then I invite
in guests and they're now implicated
right or it could be something like this
which I actually think about quite a lot
I might say that I don't want to use
Google services I'm going to object
fundamentally like actually giving
Google any my information and I might
feel very principled in my way of
behaving but it may well be that there
are many other people that I have to
communicate with that actually use Gmail
and so the idea that I can sort of
remove myself you know laterally from
contact with Gmail doesn't make sense if
my interactions are facilitated through
Google servers for instance and then we
can think about the way that incentives
work into this so in some cases we might
just try to incentivize outlets to just
straight-up tell us something about Bob
and so we can think of situations like
having that confidential informant
putting pressure on criminals to
disclose things about their
collaborators and so on or you can think
of something like you know casually
inviting people to upload their contact
lists to the servers to help you find
their friends which is really telling
the service everything about your social
network right and it took some time to
kind of think about where to put Network
effects in this sucks on me and here it
seems pretty obvious that like if you
think of network effects as creating
incentives to participate in the network
it seems like you can imagine that it's
precisely because many Associates of Bob
are on some particular social network
that he therefore has incentives to
disclose information as well to
participate and so in a way you know
it's like the decisions of other people
to be on Facebook or what-have-you that
is actually putting quite a bit of
pressure on
to then ultimately capitulate as well
and in this final idea is that we might
be justified in looking at people
precisely because they're related to
Alice right so in like kind of national
security context you can imagine that we
identify some person and we determine
that they're a terrorist and we can then
say we are justified at looking at
people two hops out from them all right
so the Association is the justification
for collecting information about these
people I guess the friends of friends is
important here too and you can think of
it as a way of protecting more about
Alice by learning things about her
associates but you can also just see it
as a excuse in a way to client kind of
collect information about Alice's
associates so this kind of deals with a
bunch of different scenarios that we
think of as being you know largely about
the kind of tie between people and it
does I think include a lot of different
things and I can imagine Trudy means
quite differently but the thinking was
that this set of things was distinct
from the next two large categories that
I'll describe okay so let me now move to
what we call similarity based
dependencies you can think about in
these terms so one outlets discloses
something about herself
she may reveal certain things about Bob
if Bob is understood to be similar to
Alice in some respect and in particular
the observer might conclude that Bob is
likely to the share of the disclosed
trait by Alice if the observer already
knows that Alice and Bob resemble told
her across some relevant dimensions this
might be a sort of fancy way of
describing the process of induction all
right we're taking a fixed set of
examples and we're trying to infer some
rule that says that this particular
sought-after feature tends to correlate
with these particular other observed
characteristics right
and it's important to at least
acknowledge that in order to apply the
rules that we might draw from
observations from alice and other
similar people to Bob we need to know
something about Bob right and what we
need to know is that Bob possesses what
we would see is the sort of relevant
characteristics that are similar to
those held by alice and others that
allow us to make it kind of
statistically motivated guess that that
bob is also going to have the as yet
undisclosed feature and i think what's
really important from the point of view
of privacy and this is a conversation
i've had independently with some other
people and remember for many years is
that unlike the sought-after trait which
might be perceived as sensitive or
worthy of protection
these characteristics which we discover
to actually be good proxies or
predictors of the trait we're looking
for might be much more readily
observable or much more freely disclosed
precisely because they're not perceived
as sensitive or or really worrisome for
other people to know about I think it's
about regularities in observations of
many people that you can yes yeah that's
right yeah and I think like the language
of Alice and Bob becomes a little
unhelpful here because it's like one
Alice but I think for the sake of this
section it's worth of thinking about
Alice and many other people like Alice
and for this section also like Bob
what's interesting actually is like the
kind of I'll end with a case study which
is actually specifically about the fact
that DNA has this kind of unique
property that it simultaneously
functions as a tie base dependency
similarity based pendency and a
difference dependency and and it's
actually like not always clear to us
like when different things are operating
but they're different and different laws
target different parts of this process
but I think is that sort of anticipating
your question okay
but so you responded to Katrina that's a
question of whether this is a
statistical attribute and what my
question is isn't it the way we learn in
general right yeah so jump ahead to
slides to to get to a point I'll come
back so yes you know we're sort of like
ear oppressively drawing rules more
experience or a way of learning about
the world in general follows this
particular pattern like you know it's
sort of foundational to human cognition
we're always making sense of any given
observation by a kind of comparing it to
other things that we've seen in the past
and with respect to a kind of individual
observations of individuals you can
think of it as that we're always sort of
making sense of any particular
observation by thinking about that
against the backdrop of other people
we've observed with similar
characteristics this is all maybe like
overly philosophical way of literally
just describing what machine money ties
right so like forget the philosophical
language just think of a traditional
supervised machine learning task so so
absolutely and other people have made
this remark for some years now
I mean largely at this point right so if
the whole point is that like seemingly
benign innocuous details can be the
basis upon which you draw an inference
that is sensitive then it sort of
doesn't really make sense to distinguish
between sensitive and non sensitive
information in separate work I kind of
try to go into details about like why
even the category is sensitive even
outside of this doesn't necessarily make
sense
we often have like very particular
outcomes in mind about how that
information will be used that explains
why something is sensitive and if we
think about in that way it also just
sort of unsettles this whole way of
thinking but yes that's a basic point
this should encourage us to kind of
abandon an idea that just like there's
no such thing as like some types of
information that are uniquely
identifying and others that are not the
same way here like there isn't something
that's sensitive information
information that is not okay and to be
clear right not only is this like the
basis of human cognition
it's also conserved like pretty
reasonably important functions and the
sense that like it may be extremely
expensive to go off and observe the
thing that we're trying to infer instead
so inference can be like enormous the
important in part because it allows us
to reduce the cost of trying to collect
that information directly you could
think of that as a bad thing in some
senses too right because maybe some of
those costs are a natural barrier to
getting an information that we don't
want to reveal or maybe the discomfort
someone might experience if you ask them
explicitly for that information so you
can sort of circumvent that altogether
and here you can imagine like that's
very dangerous because in the okay I
should say to explain this a little bit
people can think back many years to the
target pregnancy prediction scandal I
remember trying to think like what was a
simple heuristic to kind of like give a
company that doesn't want to end up
doing something like this and I remember
thinking like maybe you should not infer
something that you wouldn't be willing
to ask someone about directly which is
not the same the same thing is saying
that like you cannot infer it it's sort
of saying if you are unwilling or
reluctant to ask it probably suggests
that there are some norm that you are
violating by trying to get at that
information this way and if you're using
inference as a way to avoid the
discomfort you might experience having
to ask that question you should sort of
take take note of that right I don't
think that's a particularly helpful
heuristic because oftentimes we don't
even really know why we find certain
things like unsettling it might disclose
other things so but you could see the
point right that like there are certain
norms that were actually uncovering when
we discover that people are
uncomfortable with certain questions and
that this might be a mechanism to
circumvent that altogether
yes so let me this was sort of like the
set up I think what's important here is
that the task is often to find the ways
in which people are relevantly similar
with respect to the sought-after
characteristic and the taxonomy layout
here is by no means like really
fundamental it's just a sort of way of
cutting things that I think of as being
socially salient rather than being
technically different and so we can
think about a couple of different ways
in which might in which people might be
perceived as relevantly similar that
raised particular concerns right so one
thing might be people are relevantly
similar in the sense that they were
making inferences based on the company
they keep including potentially their
family members like who are they related
to it could be that people are similar
in the sense that they share socially
salient characteristics with other
people so things like your race or your
age or your gender or what-have-you but
you have no explicit social ties with
them right these are not people that you
know as friends or family they're simply
people have similar social
characteristics and then finally and
perhaps the most unsettling is the idea
that we might find that there are ways
in which people are relevant with
respect to the sought-after trade that
are not socially salient characteristics
at all right they're just sort of
seemingly arbitrary things that people
would not recognize as any basis for
shared identity
oh sure so imagine you have like you
know like a million a million like
pieces of information about where people
browse them on the web right and that
we're going to then produce some kind of
set like a model which is trying to
predict some particular feature and
while we might imagine that there's some
kind of patterns here that the models
learning that are relics related to you
know similar interests or something like
that it would be hard to think that like
the groups that this model has learned
sort of correspond to like socially
meaningful characteristics
a lot of times their hypothesis and
again don't understand well what happens
when it's some thing that no you don't
see the meaning that doesn't mean it's
not there well it doesn't have to be
there like we can in many cases generate
concert concert but is underlying yeah
you could be a transfer representation
there could be a whole bunch of things
that are happening and we're like even
the even the features don't have
semantics or something right where then
it doesn't even make sense to imagine
that we could think of this as some
shared social characteristics
yeah I mean we often make up these like
kind of just so stories are like some
random magazine subscription plus like
the fact that you shop at Walgreens
means that you're going to vote for you
know like these kinds of things and when
those things correspond to our
intuitions like oh yeah of course
right and when they don't they're like
oh interesting you know I thought this
isn't possibly it's not it's not to say
that this is not sort of like acting as
a proxy for something we might
eventually discover corresponds to some
distinct social group but that the model
itself is not using those
characteristics directly in the way that
it figures this out I think you had a
question to actual
not really anymore or it could be or
yeah or they could just be completely
wrong and I should I should point out
that like this is you know in this and
it's a traditional problem of adduction
like there's a bunch of reasons why this
is not necessarily true but I guess I
don't see any difference here from the
way in which we generically behave how
many of you when you go through a TSA
line this is what I asked my class when
you go through a TSA line how many of
you make judgments about the nature of
the people who are right in front of you
[Laughter]
so we're all making inferences all the
time and just ground it in a financial
one so part of the reason my husband
regulates national banks so one of the
things that the small local banks do is
they use personal knowledge about an
individual and about family and about
the church and synagogue whatever that
they go to and they then make judgments
on the ability-to-repay so I think what
you're saying here is that you're Jason
codifying or writing down the zillions
of judgments that human beings do yeah
and so in this in this separate work
which I won't go into in detail I try to
differentiate the fact that we're
constantly making inferences about each
other from what seems to be unique about
the kind of inferences we can draw with
machine learning even so right even if
we stick to the fact that humans are
doing this it's still important to
recognize that like my ability to draw
inferences about you Julia depends
crucially on things I've learned about
other people who I would see is similar
to you right so that alone I think is
the observation I'm trying to make I'm
not necessarily going to give a
normative theory about one that's okay
that's not but the very fact that like I
can bring to bear information I've
learned about others when I trying to
make sense of you is the right term you
find call this to my school okay I'll
give a tiny preview of what like the
argument could be like one one thing is
that like machine learning could
potentially learn the same kinds of
rules that we as humans have drawn from
my own experiences and the fact that we
can automate that is itself potentially
a big deal for privacy the second thing
is that we're possibly also learning to
make inferences that humans would never
be able to make and that is also itself
I think an interesting privacy question
[Music]
and I think maybe what you mean by
socially salient is like things that we
would view as a reasonable justification
versus things that humans would
or things that would intuitively make
sense versus things that appear rammed
up into humans because other I don't
know what social salience yeah I take
your point and I think also again this
other work I think I'm going the
direction you're describing here but for
this I wanted to make a different
differentiation between socially
assailant and and not because
discrimination law is this right it's
saying that like when we're trying to
make sense of people by thinking of them
as being similar on the basis of their
race or gender we're going to say that
that's wrong right okay okay what P
seems to be maybe about the visibility
of the characteristic it seems that
there's something troubling
characteristics that we wouldn't even
noticed about people being used do you
think you're good yeah yeah so here I
but they mean like I think I mean like
really what would we see is like if we
were to ask if we were that if someone
were to ask us like articulate your
identity right like what are the
categories that you might use to
describe yourself and I think like the
ways in which we see ourselves as being
similar to people in terms of our social
identities would be things like you know
where we happen to live what our
religion is these kinds of things
whereas there can be things in which
like we would never self-identify as
belonging to a group in any me evil
sense use in this category it's what I
think becomes complicated because yeah
but yes I think you're using
socially salient just in a bunch of
different ways great one you're saying
oh it's about protected attributes and
then you just said it was about ways in
which we might identify so oh you're a
university professor which is a much
broader and I when when you were talking
about like little social salience it
sounds like these are I think these are
fuzzy right but I I just think you
should just to clarify what is it that
you're trying to distinguish I mean
maybe if I go through the examples
because it says this is this the set up
I can maybe clarify but I still think
it's fuzzy like I would not assert that
this is something foundry but I take
your point yeah when you say social
salience is one thing that it seems to
me of my meanness of information
asymmetry like for example on Facebook
when I'm deciding that I'm gonna make
some things public and some things
private so I'm gonna you know make that
I'm a university professor public oh
well make the fact that I've liked
various TV shows public but all hi it's
my you know yeah
sexual orientation or something yeah
like maybe yet the reason I don't mind
you inferring things about my politics
from the fact that I'm a university
professor is because when I made it
public I sort of understood that people
could make inferences from that but when
I when you infer things about my sexual
orientation from the likes I've made
like maybe the reason why I didn't I
just comforted by that is that I didn't
realize that that that there were
correlations there that you could use to
make inferences is that yes and so I I
had this challenge of the sign which of
two things to present and I think I
didn't chose not to present would have
gone into detail about exactly this and
this is meant to just make me a more
like high-level let me talk about it but
I'm lucky terminates but yes except that
like I even worry about that being the
way we try to adjudicate because one way
to handle that problem was just to tell
everyone all the things that we're now
we're going to be able to use it as the
basis for inference and that's a
terrible world to live in as well right
we're like suddenly I now know there's a
bunch of things that might be the basis
for interest making in some sense yes
I'm aware of that but now I live in a
world
which a bunch of things I'm now doing
which I previously didn't see as
particularly telling I now have to be
very careful with because I recognize
that it might be the basis for inference
so but it also gets complicated it might
be a bad if we say that the reason we
don't like it is because it's unexpected
the response might be just make sure
it's expected and what I'm trying to say
is that like that is not a solution to
this problem if it just means that we
now have to be even more careful about
our disclosures we could we could say
all and we live in an age or data rate
and and it's interesting because I think
in the last century so like we've made
the switch in our analogies at some
point and we're taking our analogy a
little too seriously but to step back
like what I was trying to understand
privacy in social networks like it was
very clear that Facebook represents
almost all information relationally
right right like the only things that
relation everything else is and even
though so are you talking about
representations of information or are
you saying information exists somehow in
space I use no no no I'm saying that
like the way that we're able to draw
this is not observation which is
important right so it's saying that like
I observe certain things about this
group of people and I determined that
this one individual now looking at
resembles them in this set of ways which
allows me to bring to bear what I've
learned from observing things about them
to my ability to make sense of this new
person right which is literally with a
machine learning task is in general and
which is true of all inductive reasoning
and so this is not saying that like
information exists in the world and
we're just sort of uncovering it I'm
trying to describe the fact that like
the way I'm able to actually make sense
of any particular individual is
by comparing them to other people which
we I see as being similar to them and
then you're comparing that to seeing
which is maybe information but maybe
something more complex than that so I'm
like lost in this set of equivalences
and substitutions that you're making
that's easy
not sure I understand the substitution
like even if I were to stick with like
the human looking at the world so let's
forget data altogether
I don't see why what I'm describing is
is substituting okay okay okay all right
I'll try to okay so to give some
substance to this right so one
particular reason we might not like this
type of thing is that we can end up
basically punishing the Sun for the sins
of the father or something like that
right so we might say that given that we
know that Bob is the son of Alice and we
know certain things about Alice we're
going to draw some inference about Bob
right here this can be based on a couple
of different theories it could be the
idea that some things are hereditary but
it also could be some belief that
children are sort of raised by their
parents in particular ways that means
it's likely that they will end up having
certain property is that the parent had
as well and in fact we even have certain
instruments that do exactly this right
so compass people might not know has
questions which asks about the criminal
history of parents and so this is used
as a way to make a prediction about the
likelihood that someone would would
recidivate if they were released pending
trial right the Allegheny County tool
that is the subject of chapter and
Virginia Eubanks his book and also some
of the work that was done by colleagues
in the art world that to actually looks
at whether or not you are the child of
someone so to predict the likelihood
that you will be involved in some kind
of child neglect or abuse case they
actually look to see if you as a child
had been abused or neglected all right
so there's a sort of like way in which
this carries forward across different
generations
and actually there's some interesting
work that's been done by Abby Jacobs
looking at how you can actually predict
the likelihood that someone might end up
abusing opiates given the fact that they
live with someone whose abuse opiates
and so here was a bunch of reasons why
we might think this is true but like
even if we just did this statistically
forget like trying to hypothesize the
causal mechanism that generates this we
can just observe this to be true and we
have we might have some specific
concerns when it's something that's
approximate yeah so the typist is like
observing Bob directly via Alice here
this is I'm gonna say like I know that
Alice and Bob live together but I'm
gonna make an inference about Bob given
the fact I know certain things about
amber meaning agnostic both on whether
or not this is going to be accurate or
whether not even going to be something
we see as good or bad I'm simply trying
to make like the actually very basic
point that what we know about any person
depends on what we know about other
people right so there's some work that
we're doing in the paper that try to
draw up like a normative question but I
just want to make like the very basic
point and show how it works in slightly
different social configurations that we
might then have discussions about do
these configurations actually matter to
our ability to assess whether we think
it's appropriate or not
the previous slide when you talked about
the relevant irrelevant similarity the
more the the more diverse you know the
diversity of groups that we have the
diversity of information that we have
what actually allows us to define like
precisely the similarities we have more
similarities that we can compare and so
you know our prediction would be you
know yes and that actually could be like
related to the talk yes and sort of if
we think about the previous talk right
before launch that was for the direction
it was going to write which is that we
want to find other relevant similarities
that allow us to then make a better
prediction about a whole range of people
something like that okay
I'll just kind of speed up a little bit
so you know it might not be like you
know your family or the people you live
with but it might be like the people
that the company that you keep and so
the story that kind of got everyone
thinking about this was the study on
gate or for many years ago where we can
infer someone's psycho orientation based
on the fact that other people that they
are related that they're kind of
expressly connected to on the network
have disclosed their sexual orientation
there's all this work that's been done
trying to use similar data to do credit
scoring and I kind of think of I see WSM
as a conference that just kind of
specialized this isn't this work right
so like using social media data to build
models to infer all sorts of other
things and you know at this point it's
sort of arrived at the interesting
conclusion this is some work from early
this year from Garcia where it's pretty
clear in some cases that the information
that other people disclose can be more
informative than the information that we
disclosed and that made me actually
think that like this can be even so
strange we're like the disclosure of the
many Alice's that were associated to
kept saying more about me than they do
actually about Alice which is a very
interesting possibility and then to kind
of come to this like socially stealing
group idea right so you know here we can
think about the traditional way that
like marketing has been based on
demographics
and we tend not to see these things it's
particularly trouble troublesome right
like you're going to target me based on
my gender and age or something like that
but it's actually quite remarkable you
think about how much we actually are
able to infer about someone just given
those two attributes right just knowing
someone's age and gender can tell us a
remarkable amount about people precisely
because we've been able to observe
different statistical patterns across
these different populations and while we
might not find that particularly
unsettling at this point like it's worth
understanding just how powerful it is to
be able to bring observations of other
people to bear on any particular person
okay in some work that I did with Helen
a couple years ago we talked about how
this has interesting implications for
consent because it turns out that it may
not require many people to actually
disclose this information and where for
us to then be able to infer it about
everyone else and in fact it might be a
very small minority the population that
will early discloses some attribute and
then we're able to find those
characteristics that reliably predict it
and then see who else has those
characteristics and apply that inference
to the rest of the population and it's
worth explaining that of course this is
really the basis of scientific research
often what we're trying to do is find
some kind of generalizable result and so
in some sense this is a positive
externality right the degree to which I
can use this information to make
inferences about others is to everyone
else's benefit because for instance I'm
able to treat their medical condition
but we could also think of it as a
negative externality if it allows us to
infer a health condition which then used
to discriminate against them for
instance right and I guess just to kind
of put a point on this which I accept
needs work you know like the look-alike
audience function that we talked about
yesterday morning you know the goal here
to just sort of like arbitrarily find
those features which happened to be held
by other people who have expressed
interest in a particular brand or a
Facebook page and it matters not at all
what those features happen to be the
goal is just to find what features
happen to be common across all the
people that are previously interacted
with that page or brand or whatever
right and it's extremely unlikely from
my perspective that if we were to
observe what that entailed that would
actually be some set of features that
people see as being
particularly meaningful in the way that
they they're being grouped okay and then
hopefully in the remaining time we'll
talk about different space dependencies
so here the idea is that by revealing
information about herself Alice may
allow the observer to learn something
about Bob by making herself
distinguishable from Bob and you can
think of this in a straightforward said
okay we can think of this in a
straightforward situation of a process
of elimination where let's say we have
some fixed set of people who we have
suspicions of committing a crime and
then we go and ask each person to
produce some kind of alibi and as more
people produce alibis the denominator
becomes smaller and we have a greater
sense that the remaining people are of a
higher likelihood of having been the
person who committed the crime right
okay let's speed that up
so in that case just to be clear right
Alice individually is sort of disclosing
things just to prove her innocence but
in the process is actually further
implicating Bob weak also think of
anomaly detection where the ability to
actually detect what its anomalous
depends crucially on looking at what
everyone else has done right so the
behaviors of Alice and all her all other
people become the baseline against which
Bob is then compared and here you know
it could be something like the the fact
that I use electricity at a much higher
rate than my neighbors suggesting that
there might be some kind of marijuana
growing right and the way I'm able to do
this is by comparing what is the normal
level of electricity use in there in the
area or for comparable size houses to
mine
right so again like it's precisely
because I look different than all other
alice is that I'm then implicated and
then we can think of adverse inference
where here it's the refusal to disclose
certain things that allows us to then
draw an adverse inference about people
so for instance Alice might be very
willing to disclose something and my
hesitancy might suggest to the person
that there's reasons to be suspicious
about me and it's precisely because
alice is so better be willing to
disclose that it then implicates my
non-disclosure and this can be something
that's trivial as the fact that you know
yeah I'm not
going to post a photo of myself on
online dating site where everyone else
is and therefore you're going to
conclude that I must be a horribly ugly
person or if I don't post like you know
my resume on LinkedIn that there must be
something that is a little bit suspect
and I think here it's the kind of
familiar premise that you have nothing
to hide if you are going to hide
something there must be something you
want to keep secret and I think what's
very interesting about this is like
their very idea of what counts as hiding
is itself a function of what is not what
is normally done by other people right
and so even the very activity that we
would see is privacy preserving is
definitionally based on what is common
or uncommon behavior in the rest of the
population right so for instance right
like locking your door to your car
closing the door to the bathroom these
are not seen as particularly tell me
because everyone happens to do them
whereas if I go out of my way to use
encryption when everyone else doesn't
there might be reasons to be suspicious
that I'm doing something wrong okay in
the remaining seconds so then I also
want to come to what Rachel discussed
and unbaked ideas session yesterday
which is thinking of unraveling as a
particular instance of adverse inference
where in particular what we're trying to
do is rank order people and so there are
going to be incentives when I want to be
able to distinguish myself from others
to disclose that I have the kind of
desirable attribute and as we learned Bo
how they now observed that jamie has
revealed this fact will want to disclose
and the next most healthy person in the
room would go on down the line until
we've all disclosed precisely because we
wanted to distinguish ourselves from the
remaining people who are going to be
either subject to adverse inference or
assumed to kind of have like the average
score of the remaining population right
okay do I have any more time okay so
just very quickly what is interesting
about genic information is that it can
be used in all three ways and the fact
and the reason that's true is because it
has the following properties first that
it's uniquely identifying that it
demonstrates these relationships between
people and that we can use it to predict
future risks like health disorders and
so on so we talked a little bit about
the
Taipei's dependency familiar search with
Golden State but actually it turns out
that the Golden State Killer also used
this other dependency which is that we
can see that certain genes tend to
correlate with certain physiological
expression and so they actually use this
to kind of figure out what this person's
likely to look like given what we know
to be common patterns of appearance
given certain genes and they use that to
then further limit the candidate set and
then you can also think of kind of
different spatialite dependencies in the
sense that let's say we have a set of
people which we have reason to believe
or suspects in a crime we ask people to
give their their DNA and then we're
going to kind of systematically check
those people against the sample we have
people who refuse to disclose we're
going to be suspicious about so this
will be adverse inference and so again
here you can think of it as being a
mechanism to say given that this is a
finite set everyone who is proving
themselves not to be the culprit has
also been implicating the remaining
people okay and they're very very final
thing I'll say is that there's an
amazing case from a couple years ago
called the devious defecate er it's
actually a legal case has anyone heard
of this no yes okay okay so very quickly
it's actually a case that involved the
genetic non-discrimination Act or
genetic information non-discrimination
Act Gina which if you actually kind of
look at the legislative record was
designed to kind of address the first
two types of dependencies we're trying
to prevent insurers and employers from
making predictions about for instance
your health given information about your
genes and the reason it also was way to
tie base was that I wanted to prevent
them from also using your known
relationship to someone else who you
also happen to do that like their health
about right and in this particular case
there was a warehouse where apparently
someone was like defecating on the floor
of the warehouse and they couldn't
figure out who was doing this so they
actually kind of figured out who were
the people who are working at this time
and in this part of the warehouse that
would be possible suspects and they
asked those people two people in
particular to give DNA samples and it
turns out that neither of those people
were actually the ones it was no match
right but then
what endo Pepe is that they sued the
employer because they said that this was
a violation of Jeana but what's really
interesting about this is that the way
that we're going to use the genetic
information was not the tie based or
similarity based dependency it was this
different states dependency right in the
sense they were trying to figure out can
I identify that this is the person
because they have the same da as the
stool sample and interestingly it turned
out that their particular way in which
the law was written allowed for this
interpretation which said that like
genetic information couldn't be used to
make essentially like termination
determinations and so it actually was
decided in the favor of the employees
but everyone found this to be very
surprising because the intent of the law
really was not to cover that particular
problem it was designed to cover the
fact that they don't want to make
predictions about people's health right
so this is all just a kind of cute way
of saying that like the kind of
elaborate taxonomy laid out here
explains what people found quite
surprising about this legal result but
it also shows that there are laws that
are act in fact tailored to some of
these problems right so Gina is an
example where the law is definitely
trying to target the similarity based
dependencies and to some extent the tie
base dependencies but originally did not
seem to be targeting this kind of
difference based dependency okay that's
it
[Applause]
[Applause]
so thanks for the excellent talk
actually prefer to be a discussion after
I talked it's not as excellent but your
life is easier but that's what I got and
I think that discussion here was really
really useful discussion here and in Val
stock in emphasizing this point that
kind of going back and forth between the
different worlds raises all these
different concerns and different one
point of view and therefore the
discussion has to be in this level of
conceptualization rather than kind of
things that are already ready okay here
is what we as a community created take
it and do something with it and I
thought that all these perspectives were
very useful but I should say that there
are some absolute truths that we
shouldn't ignore so humans are clearly
not clocks and obviously not just
information what clearly the case is
that people are computations but beyond
that everything else was very and
another point about this discussion
things that came up in the discussion
that I thought was very interesting is
this question about what do we
understand about what a machine or
machine learning does which is very
interesting but we should perhaps
contrast it with what we understand
about what humans do and and usually we
talk about it as a rationalization when
we trying to explain perhaps to
ourselves what are we doing and it's not
clear that this difference is that and
that huge but that's a different
discussion and one thing that appears in
the paper which I really really like and
not here not in the talk was this notion
of expectation of privacy which is
something like I'm very fond of from my
years of legal education watching Law &
Order for hours and on and and I think
that time
it's interesting to think about
differential privacy in this in this
perspective as well and in the
perspective of dependencies and I think
in the chronicles of DP one of the
earliest example is this example of a
health database where studies are done
and about the connection between smoking
and cancer and and it turns out that
there is a connection and therefore
somebody a smoker is health insurance
Rises even if they weren't in the data
set and we somehow feel that this is ok
because the the smoker doesn't have an
expectation of privacy to erase all of
the information from everybody else's
information to prevent this study we as
a society would rather have this kind of
a study even though it it allows us to
compromise the privacy of this
individual that now we know as a higher
chance of being of having cancer and
there is an entire kind of way of
thinking about what does DP do or what's
the privacy in differential privacy
through this notion of what's the
expectation of privacy perhaps we think
that and erasing everybody else's
information is not reasonable but
erasing your information from the data
set and perhaps the information of a few
people that are correlated with you is
reasonable is a reasonable expectation
of privacy and there are through this
line of thinking there are other notions
and variants of differential privacy
that come up from considering different
dependencies between individuals and
there are lots of there's quite a bit of
research about variants of DP that takes
into account different kind of dependent
caesars I will mention a couple of
things pufferfish and there's a lot of
work on DP in the context of social
networks and all of this could be viewed
as what's the reasonable expectation of
privacy which is a term that allows
decision-makers to think about it in a
way that would translate later to an
exact technical definition
an exact variant of the DP and again in
this process we'll need to talk about
social norms and practices we'll need to
talk about regulations and laws but
we'll also need the theory part of DP
and we'll also need machine learning
people that will help us discover the
kind of dependencies that do exist and
take it them into account when we're
thinking about the right version of DP I
want to emphasize here X only covers
well the cases where the dependencies
Australia but also have dependencies are
their weaknesses if I told you that
there are ten people in this film or
computer scientist and if I show you
such ten people you know that everybody
else is no prize but this is rather weak
dependency in this population but what
happens more and more now is that the
ability to combine these with
dependencies together with result in
small depends for instance the senses
work on typically this will be like kind
of a fraction of that like the sender's
word combining a lot of statistics each
other and creating with dependency
between
but when you put them together you get
this from dependency you managed to
reconstruct the data very accurate that
you managed to verify above 70% of the
US population and get their exact values
these are examples of how you put this
together and I think one issue is that
one is this and there are way more with
heaven yet developed expectations to
think about usually just so
insignificant
no I agree I mean I think like I sort of
conveniently sidestepped like they're
more like explicitly differential
privacy discussion here and if I had
even attempted it it would have probably
moved in this direction but yeah I mean
I think like what was interesting to me
about the project was sort of like going
from a sense that there are maybe a
small number of well different privacy
problems plus some other things where I
feel like it's very clearly a dependency
to kind of seen it all over the place
right there was like a bunch of other
things that are not necessarily covered
by differential privacy and I was sort
of interested in thinking about like how
some of those problems might lend
themselves to similar kind of
theoretical formal work in computer
science across this entire project give
or take whether any of the details spend
scrutiny and I'm sure many of them will
my proposition is that this is a
repudiation of the definition of privacy
as control of information about
ourselves just what you say yes yeah
yeah absolutely yeah yeah yeah no no I
totally yes let's say you gave this talk
again to different audience and deleted
their word privacy and replaced it with
inference or learning does the talk
still make sense it kind of seems to me
like maybe you are telling us that
that's not to say it's not relevant to
privacy I think it's extremely relevant
Department but it kind of seems like
you're just helping us categorize ways
that the observer learns about people
and and you're giving us an interesting
example where you can learn about people
through information about some others
and then whether it's a privacy interest
or not is it as a separate question and
it's a very interesting one and and we
can learn a lot from it okay kind of in
the same way that we become have this
revolution where you know Arvind and
Paloma and all these people said oh look
you can really from pieces of
information that might be surprising and
is that necessarily privacy well it's
just it's going to be a privacy issue
because we're learning something about
how people learn information about other
people and and so I'm wondering if you
could just like put aside the privacy
for a little bit and just say this is
this is one of the many interesting ways
that people learn about other people and
then then we don't get we don't have to
immediately decide which ones are bad
and good or which ones
are against privacy or not I think like
descriptively that's probably a more
faithful account I thought what was
interesting about some of the work
though was like looking at discovery
like oh this is a problem that like the
anonymous communication and community
has worked on this is a problem that the
differential privacy community has
worked on this is a problem that like
you know like it was kind of interesting
to see like which of these had already
been like recognized as a technical
problem in some sense within computer
science which were the things that the
law has already recognized as a problem
and therefore try to regulate I think
like the similarity stuff is the most
difficult both conceptually and I think
like technically because it's like
really unstructured and like who the
hell knows how to begin to make
arguments about like what is a
reasonable inference based on the things
we can observe about others but I still
was interested in kind of being able to
say like here's what's going on and like
I was interested and then thinking to
myself in turn as well like what which
of these problems have been addressed
and Gina was a kind of fun case we're
like you know this actually seems to be
addressing something but not other
things I think Julia might have been
next minute so the whole point or at
least a major reason in using data for
research is precisely the inference and
prediction so you have the example of
the Allegheny youth children and
services so what they were able to do
was they were able to rank the
probability that a kid was going to be
abused and they gave it a score of 20 20
things and as a result of adding that
information to each individual's case in
addition to the caseworkers own best
judgment which had its own ball set
such as they were able to reduce the
maltreatment of children by large
numbers and deaths of children so I'll
talk about this a bit more so if that
seems to me not a privacy issue that
seems to me well it is right but you
know in Harrington collecting any data
in order to allocate any resources in
order to do policy effectively you are
making decisions about someone's
propensity so that's exactly right
you're using that information either for
or against them and that's at the core
what policy is about so I don't know I
totally agree and I wasn't trying to in
fact Island yes yeah the one thing I'll
just saying like what was interesting
about the allegheny example and
certainly about compass is that people
find it objectionable because it's using
information about like an immediate
relative to make an inference about this
other person and we should probe that
intuition like what is it that actually
upsets people that we might decide that
they actually need to be incarcerated
pending trial because their parents have
been involved in criminal justice system
previously or what does it mean to think
that there's a higher probability that
this person will abuse their children
because they were abused by their
parents right these are probably all
true in some sense right we can show
statistically that this is actually
there's evidence to support this but we
should ask like why do we intuitively
find this like distasteful or upsetting
I think animals like men
[Applause]